[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Dustin is
in Columbus OH higho hi Dustin welcome
to the Ramsey show thank you for having
me sure what's
up um so me and my wife we're currently
25 um we have
just taken in the uh some student loans
that were kind of like feeling a little
uneasy about that is just now hitting
about
$60,000 uh in student loan
you just took them in what does that
mean it's not a stray dog how what are
you talking about like we from Biden's
plan that he had originally had so we're
just now getting to them about the debt
loan forgivness all that stuff so now
that it's finally coming in we're like
oh we have $60,000 in student loan debt
okay you always had
it yeah and we were not paying on it
yeah if if for three years clarifies
yeah okay yep we were not paying so now
it's coming now it's coming down on you
okay I got you all right I'm with you
yep correct um as well as we have
$50,000 in auto loans so now as well as
we just had a a kid now we're kind of
sitting back yep yep what's your
household income
sir uh we each make about $80,000 a year
so 160,000 a year all right and you have
$110,000 in debt correct and you just
had a baby is a baby okay oh yep he's
healthy as can be wonderful okay so you
guys um are going to get to spend a lot
of time with a baby you're not going
anywhere uh all you're going to do is
work and be with a kid because you're
going to live on nothing and pay this
off in 18
months okay tell me about the cars the
50,000 in car
debt um so she was a travel nurse about
a couple year like probably two years
ago so we were making a good bit of
money and we both decided to go get new
vehicles and then decided that we wanted
to have a kid so she stopped traveling
and got uh a better nurse job so so what
do you owe what are the two cars you owe
50k break them down we have we have a
Ford F-150 larett we owe about 23,000 on
and then a 2019 Jeep Grand Cherokee that
we owe about 27,000 on okay are you
upside down or you got any equity in
them uh the Ford uh could probably get
about 30 out of it uh and then the Jeep
of probably out of what we owe I'll tell
you my friend I'm guessing the F-150 is
yours right it is well since Dave and
dis established you're not going
anywhere you don't need an F-150 that's
super you know Juiced up I'd sell that
F-150 today what's your car payment
what's your car payment on that about
481 we bought them when interest rates
were really low yeah but that's a
$481 raise by being a big boy and
selling that
truck okay do I get another vehicle
$7,000 one go get you a $77,000
car okay you have a baby you're a
man yeah you have a family to take care
of yeah so um now here here's the thing
here's the thing
$160,000
income $110,000 worth of debt the
difference is
50,000 so not in taxes which we have to
count if you lived on 50,000 you'd be
debt free in one
year but you guys have been spending
like you're in
Congress yeah and the student loan thing
is your wakeup call to live on beans and
rice rice and beans ramen noodles never
go out to eat never go on vacation and
possibly sell your truck so that you can
get out of debt in one to one and a half
years
okay now we have 27,000 in savings do
like that'll make it go
faster that'll make it goter pay it off
and then just have nothing in like
that's where I'm I like a pat his
savings so it hurts me to spend it so I
don't well it didn't hurt should have go
$50,000 in car debt
yeah that's when you spent it you
already spent it you just hadn't
admitted it
yet yeah are you familiar with our baby
steps uh I am I haven't started it I've
just been listening on and off for about
a year
and about the vehicle well it's okay but
get over the guilt and fix it so baby
step one is
$11,000 so that gives you 26 1,000 in
your savings account as an emergency
fund now you got
26 you guys can knock out that g Cheroke
list your debts smallest to largest how
many different student loans are
there um there's two only two what what
size are they uh they're each 30,000 a
piece okay so that's the two that's the
big one so when you list your debts
smallest to largest it goes 23 27 3030
you follow me yeah we're going to pay
minimum payments on everything but the
little one and attack the little one so
we're going to pay off her car
tonight and then you're going to decide
if you're going to keep your car if
you're going to keep it you're going to
start paying on it like a crazy man like
I'm talking you're going to set aside h
$88,000 a month for
debt okay and when you pay $88,000 a
month on 27 it goes away pretty quick
$8,000 a month on 30 it goes away pretty
quick oh and by the way you don't have
any car payments anymore so it makes it
easier to come up with
$8,000 okay $8,000 a month is $100,000 a
year okay and that that makes you debt
free in a
year okay but you're but to do that you
understand you have to have no
life yeah yeah but that's okay for one
year you can do that you're young and
you're going to clean up your mess and
you have a new baby and you have an
incredibly bright future you have great
careers that's it
yeah okay now we and I should sell my
truck not pay my truck off and then
either one I don't care but I think you
need to cons I think it would be a good
emotional and spiritual exercise for you
and your wife to discuss selling your
truck tonight after you pay hers
off okay buy a cheaper one yeah well you
you can decide you know cuz here's the
only thing it does it cuts down the
amount of time you have to live on
absolutely nothing and have no
life okay which right now is about a
year okay now as soon as you have no
debt at all then you're going to build
your emergency fund up and have that
Comfort again of 3 to 6 months of
expenses set aside that's your baby step
three we're going to help you with all
the this cuz I've been right where you
are Dustin where I I've done stupid
things and I had a baby and I didn't
know what to do and there wasn't anybody
to help me and tell me and we're here to
help you so we're we're talking real
straight to you and telling you the
truth because we love you but that but
we're here to help you so we're going to
put you guys into Financial Peace
University and we're going to pay for it
okay and you guys it's a gift to your
baby you're going to change your whole
family tree young man but you too as
adults now are going to throw your
shoulders back and quit buying
everything in sight like you're spoiled
kids and be adults adults devise a plan
and follow it children do what feels
good Y and so you're not going to do
what feels good you're going to do what
right what's smart for the future so the
30 and 40 and 50 year old version of you
to looks back and says wow see Dustin
the year I filed bankruptcy I was 28
years old Rachel was
born and from then on I've never
borrowed another dime from then on I've
tithed at my church every single week
one/ tenth of my income from then on
I've been on a budget for the rest of my
life from then on I don't buy anything
unless I pay cash for it from then on
because I said never again and the the
negative thing was I lost everything I
owned the good news was it completely
changed my life and you got the
opportunity to do it without losing
everything it's called growing up and we
all get to do it some people do it at 52
some do it at
22 my case it was 28 with the second kid
coming the year of file bankruptcy so
you don't have to do that you don't have
to be as dumb as I was we'll help you
dude we'll help you you got this you can
do it and by the way the Straight Talk
at dinner tonight when we talk about the
cars is I'd float the idea of her doing
a few nights or weekends with that
nursing background while you're watching
baby cuz you're not going anywhere
anyway and all of a sudden we've
increased our income to fast forward
what Dave is already laid out so we can
beat this in a year but it is going to
take big boy pants and big girl pants
sacrifice sacrifice your lifestyle lay
your lifestyle down and just put it just
shoot it just just shoot it live like a
college student